dumb hello there reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey we're gonna do a
video podcast that's right where we
don't cut it whatever we say could be
dumb or clever or smart it's time to
have a serious discussion today I think
talking about movie news and
hypothetical scenarios is one of the
most important things you could do on
the Internet
definitely this is a topper war two
requests from a man named Michael B you
might have seen our video we did with
him about Dreams solo villain origin
movies that was a great time I really
had a wonderful time film with the guy
Omni media go check his channel out so
his request this time was not to join us
whoever again franchise has gone off the
rails that you wouldn't want the that
you would want the original cast to
return to save I think this is inspired
by the fact that Sam Neill is returning
for Jurassic world 3 we know Jeff
Goldblum helped get Jurassic world
falling Kingdom over a billion dollars
right all the Goldblum all that plug all
right John let's just hop right into
this you kick it off buddy what do you
think what franchise can be resurrected
properly saved well I mean the first the
first one that came to mind I'm is good
give me some and get out of the way
quick and I think alien is one that
definitely excited people when they're
like we're gonna do the sequel thing and
then they didn't and then Halloween did
it instead I'm so sick of feminism John
yeah that's right that's why I'm
probably gonna waste so sick of it
that's right well get ready cuz anytime
a woman does anything I'm like in my
face well maybe you could just reboot
predator and only bring back Arnold
because it's the only person you could
bring back from the original prison
that's more like it you know and then
you can just have it be like a
one-on-one versus movie or something but
for actually I think wait why are we
just jumping topics here alien would be
great John that would be a great call
all the alien movies have kind of gone
downhill since Sigourney Weaver started
in alien 3 yeah yeah
but I think your specific reference to
the neill blomkamp the idea of bringing
back new tix Hicks yeah Hicks Magee
expand and Ripley obviously doing that
whole Halloween loader yeah and get
Bishop back to they all have an age at
all that would be great no Jones sorry
wrong movie cat but yeah getting all
them back would be really cool I'd be
excited for that I mean I feel like all
of us would be very excited for that the
alien aliens is I think a little more
reference than alien is and I feel like
fans would be very excited for that what
about you guys in the comments huh would
you want Hicks and Ripley Newt to return
isn't thinking of this list I started
thinking about a lot of franchises and I
was like I I started to realize that
franchises that could be saved by the
cast are a different breed than like
franchises that could be saved by like a
director or something cuz like Pirates
of the Caribbean came to mind then I was
like it wouldn't ever matter if you got
the original cast back because they've
been there for half the movies and it
really changed once you know they got
out of part three into complete
blockbuster rollercoaster Derringer well
the next one is not gonna have Johnny
Depp yeah all you need is saving because
that franchise has gone downhill ever
since they announced that that it's been
really on the uppity up since then
alright alright and then I thought you
know maybe the mummy but that the
original cast saw that through to part
three and no Rachel weas we Rachel yeast
infection was not brought back that's
true after they feminists the [ __ ] out
of The Mummy Returns and everybody
outcry I wanted my feminism face of hot
women fighting five months
behold watch they give me returns when
we were at Dan and Alyssa's wedding at
the hotel it was so much fun
they don't make popcorn flicks like that
anymore they just know how to adjust me
nothing but fun oh well you know in the
castle alone wouldn't save it they got a
different director for tomb raider
subtitle that's where they went wrong
hit the mummy - The Mummy three tomb
raider - created yeah but yeah Tomb of
the Dragon Emperor was a pretty terrible
film but I think bringing back the
director and Rachel Weisz would really
help a lot cuz maria bello as great of
an actress as she is she is not good at
that role she was very bland I think you
would I don't know Brendan Fraser
returned well that's the other things I
thought those movies I found out kind of
broke him physically I don't think yeah
would be the thing is in trying to
formulate this I kept running into these
pitfalls of like I thought Nightmare on
Elm Street would be great but they
already made new nightmare just kind of
probably the only Avenue you can go down
if you've got the original nightmare and
almost recast back you know they did
know wasn't the last nightmare still
Jackie Earle Haley yeah that was the
last one so I think bringing back
[Laughter]
there's an e however speaking of Edward
Furlong from dusk till dawn the
franchise if you brought back the
original movie cast and and did some
kind of weird follow-up on that you
could theoretically correct that even
yes show was pretty good for an old man
Seth and I remember Robert Englund I
remember George Clooney's character well
I mean I I don't want to be opposed to
that
I think that a franchise like well I
rely like the from dusk till dawn show
though I thought what I thought what
they did with the characters there it
was great
it's not the definitive one but yeah I
really think this one while I enjoyed
the reboot and the minority here I don't
prefer it over the originals and I think
we can all agree this franchise would
definitely be saved if you had just made
a part three instead of a reboot I'm
talking about Hellboy Hellboy would have
easily been a lot more profitable and
probably just got Rob Perlman literally
its it is Guillermo del Toro's movie but
the one truly campaigning for it was Ron
Perlman oh yeah and righto that's number
four you know stuff like that
I don't know oh yeah and I forgot the
other thing now when we have a little
bit more graphical capability on this
channel where it's easy to just drop
things and we can just keep a counter
each video of all my fun phrases and
then if we ever make toys dude we can
just have each of our buffer words is
all the fun faces damn you had original
three and I did that was the fourth one
but whatever we're getting off topic
here Hellboy would be greatly saved
having Ron Perlman come back honestly
even if you don't get gear I'll back you
get Ron Perlman and you get a show yeah
if you get there they would it would
make a big difference because you'd have
no choice but this sort of adhere to the
aesthetic you know it gets heiko ytt to
direct work see they think about this is
that I I wonder because the walls are
good like the fact that so many the just
the walls have come down on sequels in a
sense and we can do this thing now where
it's it's already becoming a trend where
we're going ignore all these sequels and
we're just going to attach something to
this part of story like it wouldn't be
the same thing doing that with Hellboy
now but I feel like in wake of what just
happened with the newest Hellboy movie
now is probably a better time than ever
maybe in a couple years to start that
Hellboy
three conversation because maybe people
would finally be like we want to see
this version play people would be happy
I think people would be happy about it I
mean I think the audience responds to
the elbow reboot was definitely better
than the critical response but let's
face it everyone would rather still get
a Hellboy three and then I'll follow up
to this last one you know although I
wouldn't mind a follow-up the make up
and it's great
but yeah you had quite a few I have
three franchises
one of them was alien you have like I
have 19 I have three no no those are all
the ones I was gonna just quickly
mention yeah I mean if we share alien
then I basically have two that I think
that I really came up with his answers
where I'm like yeah this company work
you know what else you got
I'm gonna go I'm gonna save my best one
for last but I think maybe if you really
brought the stars together and you got
the original Korean it wouldn't just be
the original cast if you got like all
the original crew behind scary movie
the original scary movie like those
first two even if one is regarded as
better than the other that's the only
time were know that franchise I think we
could all agree on a certain level of
enjoyment for those movies it's one of
the few parody franchises that went
pretty deep in terms of linear one name
of this franchise installments it's not
like the Freiberg seltzer verse where
they're all kind of the same thing it's
like there are five scary movies and
they all kind of diluted over time but I
feel like if you really got the whole
Wayans clan Wayans clan back and on a
ferris back and you know other comedic
actors I'm trying to think now I'm
blanking oh like the people but you know
if you got Shawn and Marlon Wayans back
on screen and the rest of the army of
Wayans is behind the camera like that
could perhaps be fun because also two
horror has grown it keeps growing and I
know Marlon Wayans has made like the
haunted house movies and stuff but again
that's just Marlon Wayans I think yeah
you could smooth like hereditary and in
babadook
the thing you see what you pointed out
is any pending you kind of could because
what you pointed out to me was that even
though I think scary movie three and
four pretty funny still in an airplane
kind of way the production value does
change and what you point out to me is
that the first two do handle themselves
a lot more like actual horror movies
than the second way ads look yeah and so
I feel like maybe in the way that some
of Horrors aesthetics have evolved and
the look and the filmmaking styles have
evolved that could actually be kind of I
mean a third of scary movie 3 was a
parody yeah man why guy trying to grow
up in a ghetto black neighborhood it'd
be a rapper oh my god that was real it's
the real sheriff who's on the cameo app
doing shoutouts so uh sponsorship in
that back to gay porn hope so
that's it well I I don't think your
scary movie ideas but I mean we're the
[ __ ] of the Wayans brothers been as a
unit I have no I mean those two those
two I think there's 76 and all they're
you know offspring who have cropped up
to be in yeah - yeah I mean I don't
think that's a bad call I think that
having them back would definitely bring
back the honestly I kind of fell off the
rails after part two part one was
literally the only well-regarded one
yeah whereas part two part twos I don't
love / - personally I kind of prefer
three / - I like three I like I have
three has the same comedic approach to
me that airplane has so there's a
certain level of effort that I
appreciated yeah but the Wayans brothers
have a very specific kind of humor very
different flavor yeah for sure um but
you know I I think I think i franchised
that I haven't even seen the reboot but
I'm pretty sure based off of
but watching the trailers and from
hearing what everyone else had to say
about it just seems apparent that I
think the men and black franchise are
greatly benefited from Will Smith coming
back I thought of men in black that uh
who we should talk about this cuz like
the thing with men in black is that the
world should be bigger than the two main
leads it should that the world should be
more appealing than those two characters
unfortunately it's not I mean you need
someone with that kind of energy and
charisma and I think that people would
have only been as men and black is so
closely tied to Will Smith more than
Tommy Lee Jones it's so linked to his
image that I like not having him in it
is you're very aware of that yeah and
you know yeah and I think I think it
would box office wise it would have
performed better if you did it men in
black for Will Smith as opposed to a
reboot you honestly probably could have
the same shitty film and then have Will
Smith in it and probably would have made
more money I guess the reason I
ultimately didn't go with men and black
because I thought to myself like ah I
think it would take a lot more than the
cast it's like it's got to be in the
writing somewhere cuz I keep wondering
why men in black hasn't had more than
one definitively good movie oh yeah yeah
I have one special film like that black
is special that's a special movie I love
that film and the other ones are kind of
whatever yeah they all feel like they're
attempting to like where the men in
black costume but they're not fully it
for some reason and it's weird cuz it
seems like a universe that would be so
easy to walk around in true true and I I
agree with that and that's why I'm
saying the world needs to be bigger and
then then it's agent it's kind of weird
how it falls under that and then you
think there are so many people working
in MIB how did they there are only 26
letters
do you have double letter agents or do
we just stack them up and hope everybody
knows what you mean that's a good point
I never even thought of that
never thought about that do they just
have a really small 2060 that whole room
is there all the whole office is lino by
alphabet yeah oh man what's your third
one my best one yet I thought to myself
what could be exciting and what could be
unexpected and also benefit because you
know the original a lot of the original
cast did leave eventually they swapped
out the kid and all that if we brought
back the original cast to do a new home
alone think about how crazy that could
be because we could confront the past
through the characters if you Center it
around an adult Kevin McCallister I was
having some kind of family reunion right
when like we still got Catherine O'Hara
around whoever's the guy who played the
dad I'm sure he exists still unless he's
dead I don't know he was at my dad's
funeral really yeah and I didn't know my
dad knew him and to this day I don't
know is they Wow both have to look but
uh okay so you know maybe there's some
kind of family reunion you know and then
Kevin is realizing through his own
children that like you know things have
trickled down from his family to him
because he kind of had a horrible family
it was kind of a jerk of a kid in a lot
of ways so you know you can have that
but then also guess what
you got to add in some kind of travel
element haven't quite cracked that yet
but it's many years later the Wet
Bandits their parole is up they're out
of prison you get Joe Pesci and the
other guy to come out of retirement and
like come back and get everyone together
it doesn't even have to be good at this
point but if you get that entire cast
back together and you know bringing some
new kids for the future home Alone's
five or whatever it could be great or or
hear me out here the protagonists are
the Wet Bandits oh [ __ ] they're in jail
oh no everyone goes on a prison trip
Kevin is bringing his kids to the prison
to scare them straight and they have no
discipline they set up traps for Kevin
McCallister
right yeah yeah Kevin the bag I know
would see that come and then you could
even bring back the trailer yeah you
didn't even bring back like they could
freak him out at one point with the old
movie that he hasn't heard in years hmm
that I only just discovered yesterday is
a fake movie within a movie that he
plays yeah
keep the change that movie yeah angels
with filthy souls or whatever it's
called I think I think open up lost it
had one and it's Halloween they did it I
mean you look at they're doing another
sequel I think they're still like ignore
the sequel we just make a you know bring
back the guy who played Jason because
the franchise just hasn't been the same
and bring we all notice the original boy
who played Jason in the first movie and
you know resurrect the woman she's not
with us still is she the woman who
played Pam bring back Pamela Voorhees
and her sweater I don't think so
I feel like she has shuffled the mortal
coil but um I would love to see her in
another movie oh I think we I think we
like really dissected this down to the
best possible chord you can do it at
mm-hmm
because there's I mean if a movie has a
remake does that qualify it as a
franchise if the if like let's let's
take Point Break for like if Point Break
you need Patrick Swayze's past so yet
what break then you have a remake I
haven't seen Point Break I'm just lazy
died in it I don't remember I don't know
that's not my scene
I feel very foggy I feel like he gets
away somehow but I don't remember
exactly it's been Sarah we watched it we
had meatball subs I really enjoyed
myself I marveled at how good of a
performance Gary Busey gives because
like everybody is on a different level
of that
imagine ringing back Gary Busey Arab
usury petty but not key honoree but not
would be good definitely yes okay so
what are some remakes that have come out
recently remakes um franchise films just
a movie that's been remade hmm okay we
just had a remake the only thing I think
of it this exact moment is Pet Sematary
there's like fourteen remakes a year I
know no one either don't think of an
elephant
they all just get lost in the zeitgeist
you know what I thought of that while
you think of a remake I realized I
thought of Jurassic Park and and and
hearing that Sam Neil is gonna come back
for Jurassic world 3 I think you have to
truly the only thing that would like
really make me interested in another
Jurassic Park movie to the point that I
don't care how it turns out I just want
to see it is if you brought the entire
original cast who survived back you know
if you really got everybody cuz because
it we've proven with Jurassic Park I
guess arguably to and forward that a
partial original Jurassic Park cast does
not work like you brought back Jeff
Goldblum for the last one it didn't help
other than to sell tickets so like if
you brought back everybody I think that
could work no little boy - yeah bring
back - little boy make him Chris Pratt's
brother and then hey up everybody who
thought he was Chris Pratt I could just
imagine the opening scene in Jurassic
world 3 or Sam Neill the Caribbean it
takes place moments later after he's
chilling he's got a bunch of like
Hawaiian hos around him right he's like
this is an island just call like a hot
call but worse and then there's just a
shadow of a Tara day damn is cut
I want him to be like the thing is if
they bring if they just bring him back I
really want that character to have
changed I really want him to be over
this now and I want him to be gruff and
grumpy like I want him to be Harrison
Ford for this movie yeah very well those
are all the movies no other movies I
know I feel like we're dredging all the
things that could have like I thought
rush out but like every rush hour has
the exact like yeah they've had a show
that doesn't count yeah it's like it's a
lot of things where I'm like huh
director how come we never got an Evil
Dead 2 that I would love to see actually
if that counts for this argument I would
get genuinely excited because I was
always on board for that like Joo and
Evil Dead remake 2 and then find a way
to like you could have crossed Mia into
the ash versus evil did a show perfectly
yeah you could segue the those movies
into that show and I can we never made a
sequel to that Evil Dead movie it was a
hit I don't I don't honestly know and I
feel like every because he didn't have
an ash and very few people remember Mia
you remember me I know well and I yeah I
feel like you think of that movie I feel
like that movies notable but I feel like
what people remember is just like the
attitude and the blood and the like hard
cornice of it more than any individual
character yeah so like oh yeah yeah I
get you but every so often I'll see it
pop up and sometimes even fede alvarez
will be like you know which would you be
interested in this or Evil Dead 2 is so
like you know it comes up in
conversation sometimes the jaws
franchise bring back that shark shark
and Richard Dreyfuss drivers yeah
do another CG resurrection of oh god
Andrews gonna kill me Roy Scheider no oh
the dude who gives the monologue yeah
yeah passed away before the movie came
out yeah that's right you never got to
see a Robert Shaw yeah there you go
well guys do you have any
Chaz's a think could be saved he brought
back the original cast Oh last one
okay if you I thought this could be
interesting and it could start a new
trend because then you could I thought
of that I segue to this idea from
spider-man because I just thought I like
those original movies it would be neat
to see a cast come back old man Pete no
and then I thought if you brought back
the cast of Tim Burton's original Batman
and made a sequel to that universe and
just kind of embrace the idea of
multiverses and then just did that like
that could be neat you mean Michael
Keaton yeah bring back Michael Keaton
and you bring back Michelle Pfeiffer if
you want to anybody from that University
you want to bring back and do like in
welcome and perhaps no but in my theory
of what this would do to franchise is
then you could theoretically go into any
franchise pick any sequel you like and
go we're spinning it off of this one no
you know it's still like well I think
another Spiderman for with the old man
Pete would be cool I think it would be
get Tobes macGuire back old man Mary
Jane yeah old man Jay jonah Jameson old
man Aunt May like pretty soon there are
gonna be no rules than if there's just
enough interest in anything you can just
bring it back with that cast if they're
around and they want to do it that's
true so why not Michael B thanks so much
for requesting this buddy guys have you
seen his channel yet it's great the guys
I was taking off his shirt during
reactions he gets so jacked up but he
watches a Kingdom Hearts trailer he just
takes off his shirt is really
distracting I'm surprised none of his
thumbnails have him with his shirt off
don't be self-conscious man that's the
best kind of clickbait material people
will definitely click on that they see
your rock-hard abs your chiseled chest
your obnoxiously gross right tricep yeah
well I would suggest even just streaming
that way like you know stream shirtless
or in your underpants you know a take
off your underpants if you want to have
the camera coming from below yeah yeah
maybe you know like be tasteful put a
sock on yourself or something but
sex sells men
not more than almost sex almost this is
the best kind yeah that's the kind you
can splash on a billboard nope almost
sex